معنا من رام الله مدير مكتب الجزيره وليد
العمري اهلا بك وليد اذا اجتماعات مهمه
بالتزامن مع مظاهرات لعائلات الاسرى
والمتضامنين معهم هل رشح اي جديد في
اسرائيل بخصوص هذه الصفقه
المرتقبه في اسرائيل يصفون هذه الايام
بانها ايام الحسم بما يتعلق وهذه الصفقه
المرتقبه لكن اجتماعات الليله الماضيه لم
تصل الى ايه نتيجه لان في اس يقولون انهم
لم يتلقوا بعد رد حركه حماس على المنحى
المقترح الذي تم التوافق بشانه في اجتماع
باريس وبالنسبه لاسرائيل وخلافا لما اعلنه
رئيس الوزراء نتنياهو من انه لن يفرج عن
الاف من الفلسطينيين الاسرى الا ان
المؤشرات بان ليس لدى اسرائيل مشكله
بالافراج عن الاف من الاسرى الفلسطينيين
لانها اعتقلت منذ بدايه هذهه الحرب على
غزه والتي دخلت اليوم يومها
ال19 اعتقلت اكثر من
6400 فلسطيني ابقت منهم نحو 4000 واكثر
داخل السجون بالاضافه ل
5300 معتقلين ومحكومين قبل بدايه هذه
الحرب في السابع من اكتوبر لذلك مساله
العدد ليست هي المشكله والحديث الذي تسرب
عن
اجتماعي المجلس الحرب والطاقم الوزاري
الامني السياسي المصغر بان الخلاف هو حول
النوعيه او كما يقولون ان يكون هناك اسر
وازن لان ما كان قد عرض او وصل الى
اسرائيل عما تقترحه حماس هو اولا بانها
تريد هدنه او وقف لاطلاق النار قد يستمر
من 10 الى 15 عاما متواصله وايضا ان يكون
الافراج يشمل في مراحله المتلاحقه على
الاقل
اسرى وازن من امثال عباس السيد
وا
وايضا عبد الله البرغوثي واخرين مثل احمد
سعدات ومروان البرغوثي واخرين من
المعتقلين المحكومين لعده سنوات من المؤبد
وهذا ما ترفضه اسرائيل حتى الساعه في جميع
الاحوال ما تسرب عن الاحاطه التي قدمها
رئيس وما يدور في هذه الاجتماعات ان
التقديرات ووفق مصدر سياسي اسرائيلي وصف
بالكبير نقلت عنه وسائل الاعلام
الاسرائيليه بان احتمالات نجاح هذه الصفقه
لا تتعدى 50% والحديث يدور حاليا عن
المرحله الاولى منها وهي ان يتم الافراج
عن
35 من المدنيين والاطفال والنساء
الاسرائيليين المحتجزين والاسرى في قطاع
غزه في مقابل ان يكون هناك 100 و50 مقابل
اسيرا فلسطينيا مقابل كل واحد منهم
ويوم هدنه مقابل هذا كل واحد من هذا العدد
ال
35 اسيرا اسرائيليا اي
35 يوم هدنه ويتبعها اسبوع او عشره ايام
من المفاوضات للتمهيد للمرحله الثانيه
وهكذا بالنسبه للمرحله الثالثه لكن في
اسرائيل التصريحات والواقع على الارض يشير
الى ان اسرائيل حاليا لا تفكر في هذه
الصفقه وهي ماضيه في حربها على قطاع غزه
وهو ما اشار اليه بالاساس تصريحات وزير
الدفاع امس وكذلك و هيرتس ليفي رئيس هيئه
الاركان وايضا رئيس الحكومه نتنياهو الذي
يعود ويؤكد رفضه الافراج عن الاف وانه لن
يقبل باي هذه الشروط وان الحرب ستمضي حتى
تحقيق اهدافها مهما كان الثمن في خلال هذا
كله كان وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي جال قد
تلقى اتصالات هاتفيا من نظيره الامريكي
اوستن بحث فيه ايضا تطورات هذه المفاوضات
وضروره مضاعفه ادخال المساعدات الانسانيه
الى قطاع غزه وتخفيف حده الحرب او جبروت
الحرب الاسرائيليه على القطاع لتجنيب
المدنيين بالاضافه لمنع توسع الحرب لتشمل
الضفه الغربيه وايضا لبنان وبخصوص لبنان
المعلومات التي في اسرائيل تشير الى
ان الموفد او المبعوث الامر الرئاسي الخاص
عامس هشتن سيصل مطلع الاسبوع المقبل من
اجل مواصله جهوده لتحقيق تسويات بين لبنان
واسرائيل في 13 ع نقطه حدوديه وفي غضون
ذلك وصل الى اسرائيل ان وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه بلينكن سيرج قدومه ووصوله لعده
ايام بدل ان يصل مساء السبت سيتا اخر
يومين او ثلاثه في قدومه ويبدو ان هذا
يرتبط اصلا في كل مساله المباحثات
والمفاوضات الجاريه حول هذه الصفقه
واسرائيل تقول انها ما زالت تنتظر لتسمع
رد حركه حماس على المنحى المقترح في مؤتمر
باريس من اجل المضي قدما لكن تقديراتها
بان نسبه النجاح لا تتعدى
50% وان قواتها الحربيه في قطاع غزه تواصل
هذه الحرب ووزير الدفاع اشار الى انها
ستنتقل بعد خان يونس الى منطقه رفح في
اشاره الا انها ماضيه في تصعيدها رغم ما
اجرته من اعاده انتشار لقواتها في شمالي
القطاع شكرا لك وليد العمري مدير مكتب
الجزيره كنت معنا من رام الله